pour parler de l'importance de fierté
montréal avec nous une des drag queens
les plus connues au canada fait
peut-être encore peu connue au monde et
à bagua merci d'être là merci de me
recevoir le festival fierté montréal ont
été importants pour vous pour votre
carrière qu'est ce qu'il représente pour
vous maintenant aujourd'hui j'ai évolué
comme professionnel pendant cette
édition à fierté montréal comme
directrice de la programmation et
maintenant je suis de l'autre côté sur
la scène donc pour moi c'est une façon
de briller mais aussi de rester en
contact avec cette estivale là que j'ai
évidemment tatoué sur le coeur donc
d'ailleurs demain vous avez votre
spectacle le spectacle qui s'appelle
drague superstore parlez nous en à quoi
on peut s'attendre alors c'est la plus
grande édition du genre on a pas eu
d'événements durant les deux dernières
années pour des raisons que je crois que
l'on connaît maintenant et on est très
excité c'est un rassemblement de drag
queen et king qui ont eu du succès à
travers différentes plateformes ça soit
des compétitions de drague grèce ou
encore calmée modo au canada ou queen of
the universe aussi partout dans le monde
donc on a rassemblé ses talents là et on
les offre gratuitement sur scène demain
soir 20h et vous vous attendez à des
milliers de personnes parce qu'avant la
pandémie donc on ne parlera pas il y
avait 23 mille personnes qui s'étaient
rendues à votre spectacle vous pouvez à
accueillir un peu plus de monde mais pas
tant que ça non plus la capacité
maximale de l'esplanade du stade
olympique c30 nil donc trente mille
personnes ce serait l'objectif oms
jamais on débute halte estivale on avait
passé rassemblé vingt trois mille
personnes comme ce fut le cas lors de la
dernière édition donc tout est possible
pour des mecs donc vous parler d'une
fête liée à sa race entre des milliers
de personnes mais est-ce que fierté
montréal est purement festif où il ya
encore un rôle de sensibilisation qui
est important pour le festival mais
évidemment le festival c'est un
événement qu'il fédérateur qui à
plusieurs pamphlets panneaux plusieurs
destinations vocation de l'aspect
ludique que je représente avec le
spectacle d'un mec mais les événements
phare est le défilé et la journée
communautaire et le bus en fait de
mettre la lumière sur des communautés
plus marginalisés et le combat de la
diversité sexuelle et de genre est
toujours d'actualité dans 70 pays dans
le monde on ne peut pas être qui on est
si on se dit queer ou dans la diversité
sexuelle et de genre donc nous on est
surpris village le au québec à montréal
et ont les ressources pour les défilés
les gens qui demandent pourquoi fait
encore des filets mais on va faire un
défilé tard et aussi longtemps qu'ils
auraient besoin qu'on fasse un défilé
c'est à dire qu'on ne va pas les quitter
on n'aura pas l'égalité partout et que
chaque personne ne pourra pas être libre
dans son pays et vous parlez de 70 pays
dans le monde vous parlez de d'un débat
qui est encore très actuel nous pas plus
tard qu'hier on présentait un portrait
de la criminalité au pays portrait de
statistique canada qui dit que les
crimes haineux sont en hausse et les
crimes haineux bon si des crimes de
nature religieuse de nature raciale mais
de nature d'identité sexuelle aussi est
ce que vous le sentez encore ce défi-là
qui existe au canada c'est une
discrimination qui existent encore au
canada je crois que la part des miens
exacerbée certains comportements sociaux
qui sont plus néfastes et
malheureusement la discrimination envers
les personnes la diversité sexuelle et
de genre en fait partie est ce que je le
ressens personnellement non est ce que
je le constate et le voit ou oui je
pense entre autres mon ami collègue marc
bloch dit se battre pour faire lors du
compte dans une bibliothèque avec des
enfants donc ce sont tous des
comportements qui sont guidés par la
peur et l'ignorance alors qu' on ne
choisit pas dedans la diversité sexuelle
et de genre comme on ne choisit pas
donné le chocolat plus que la vanille
donc quand les gens comprennent ça je
crois que il ya une ouverture qui doit
s'installer se respecte et on vit dans
le respect et je pense que si on est
dans le vivre et laisser vivre on ne
peut qu'être dans un moment mais est ce
que vous vous inquiétez de cette
tendance là où c'est kremlin ne sont à
la hausse ou vous pensez que peut-être
davantage de personnes qu'il est
rapporté qu'on s'envoie dans la boue
direction c'est difficile d'évaluer ça
quand on voit des statistiques comme ça
vous qu'est ce que vous ressentez est-ce
que c'est est ce qu'on s'en va dans la
bonne direction au toit je ne sais pas
s'il ya eu plus ou qu'on n'en rapportent
plus de chaos d'événements chose
certaine ce n'est pas des événements
isolés on le sait un peu partout dans le
monde et encore des crimes haineux qui
soit de toutes les 2 es lgbt kufor be
possible je crois cependant qu'un
dialogue la représentation maintenant
dans la sphère médiatique et donc un
dialogue et les gens comprennent plus la
réalité de nos communautés donc oui on
s'en va vers la bonne direction mais il
ya encore du chemin à faire donc je veux
pas que vous voulez c'est sur une note
négative c'est un festival qui est quand
même festif et familial aussi avait
justement alors c'est un festival qui
dépasse la communauté lgbt plus qu plus
on est dans un festival qui
communautaire qui montréalais qui est
canadien qui internationale aussi
ensemble demain votre spectacle
accueille
ddd star d'un peu partout dans le monde
oui et justement le festival de la
fierté à plus de 150 événements qui
visent tous les gens en fait et on n'a
pas besoin de s'identifier dans les
communautés pour participer être allié
démontré son support en se présentant
aux événements c'est une bonne façon
aussi de faire avancer les choses
j'étais bagarre merci d'avoir été parmi
nous mais aussi je souhaite un très beau
spectacle un très bon festival
merci beaucoup nous l'avons cherté et
merci au revoir